good afternoon everybody I know it's a
challenge to attend the talk immediately
after lunch but I'm trying to I try to
keep this short and sweet so my name is
AJ I work as a data scientist at
opensignal so today I'm going to talk
about a library that I built that let
you do fast offline reverse geocoding so
this is the outline of the talk so I'm
going to start off giving you a
background about opensignal what we do
there and tell you why I built this
library then I'm going to talk about how
I implemented it so give you more
details about you know the library and
then I'll give you a demo on how to use
it I'll then discuss the performance
results so the TL DR version is that it
can do code like 10 million coordinates
in less than 30 seconds I'll then show
you how its applied within opensignal so
you can get some ideas on what to do in
your in your own company and lastly this
is an open source library so I'll
discuss some of the contributions that I
received from the community which I'm
really thankful for so on with the show
so what is open signal so open signal
specializes in wireless coverage mapping
so what we do is we crowdsource our data
from users of our Android and iPhone
apps and we collect data in the form of
signal strength signal quality data
speeds in yeah celula as well as Wi-Fi
and till date we've basically collected
about 40 1,000,000,000 cellular data
points 50 billion Wi-Fi data points and
our users have run approximately ninety
three million speed tests and what we do
is we provide insights as to which is
the best operator in at a given location
in terms of coverage as well as data
speeds we also run reports that you can
see online like you know the state of
LTE just to see what else how I LTE is
across the globe and recently we've
launched an application called Wi-Fi
mapper which you should check out like
it will let you find free Wi-Fi hotspots
around you so as I said we basically
collect about you know 15 million data
points per day
and we would like to know where this
data is coming from in terms of
locations so a reverse geocoding is
quite important in what we do which is
basically converting a set of GPS
coordinates in two locations so as I saw
there were like a few options that were
open to me one was using online web
services like Google Maps and
openstreetmap but what I found is that
it's a very restrictive in terms of you
know the number of requests that you can
make for a day and of course you can
trick the system like openstreetmap
isn't as smart as google maps but that's
not the point it's very slow and so some
of the offline options is using a
purchase databases so for that what you
need to do is you need to have some kind
of bounding box are defined like a
polygon shape file that defines what the
you know the region looks like for a
given place but it's it gets very
complex since it's not very scalable and
it's quite slow there's also a Python
library which I'll talk about next so I
mean the motivation was basically to
build a fast offline reverse geocode ER
so I found this library that was built
by a Richard penman but there was some
limitation so I also I've improved on
that you know in the following ways so
basically the new library supports
Python versions two and three and it
geocodes a lot more information so
besides the place name and the cut and
you know the country code you also get
administrative regions levels one and
two and also the coordinates of that
place so you can see how far it is from
your input coordinate but the key
feature is performance you know the like
the library is open source and it's a
licensed under lgpl and to date it's
receive about 2,600 downloads with 41
commits from five committers so it's
received pretty good response from the
community now the implementation so the
library has two modes basically mode one
is a single process mode so it's very
simple but the default mode is more
to which is multiprocessor it exploits
you know the CPUs and codes that you
have on your machine the source of the
data is the geo names database and you
know the library comes with a list of
places that have a population of greater
than 1000 and you know the total number
of places and cities is about 145,000 so
but when you load the library all these
GPS coordinates of these places are
loaded into a KD tree and I use the
nearest neighbor algorithm to find out
which is the which is the place closes
to your input coordinate now for mode
one that's basically a class that's
provided by side pie that does this it's
called CKD tree and it implements the
nearest neighbor algorithm but it's a
single-threaded so I've basically
extended that class for more two and
implemented a paralyzed version of it so
the dependencies for this library are
numpy and scifi now the paralyzed KD
tree so basically i use the multi
processing module so the advantage over
the threading module i think this was
mentioned in one of the first talks
today here it's that it exploits you
know the multiple cores and cpus and
also doesn't have the global interpreter
lock limitation basically each process
has its own interpreter and therefore
its own Jill so you don't have that
limitation but the cons are that it has
separate memory spaces so you have to do
some form of IPC or shared memory so i
use the latter approach for the library
so basically there's a very simple
shedule ER that divides the input that
you provide into fixed chunks and the
number of chunks is equal to the number
of course that you have on your machine
and these chunks are processed in
parallel and the output is written back
down into the shared memory so it's
quite a simple architecture conceptually
and the KD tree basically has you know
the 444 following settings that are set
like the
the distance that I use is you know the
Euclidean distance although this is not
the most accurate distance measure that
you can use for GPS coordinates it works
quite well for places and administrative
region since you're dealing with a much
higher level but I am working on the
have a sign distance formula which will
be released in the next version so
please you can keep track of that on
github and the distance upper bound is
infinity so basically what this means is
that I query the entire tree to find the
nearest neighbor I mean you could
optimize it if you if you want just
query a smaller subset but this works
one good tutorial that I would recommend
is this one on multiprocessing by sturla
malden so I basically got a lot of
inspiration from that to implement this
class now i'll give you a quick demo on
how to use this library so i have a
ipython book great so you would install
the library like any other so you just
use a pip to install the reverse geocode
a library and this is how you would
import it let me just run that now this
is an example a very simple example on
how to geocode as a single coordinate so
the library expect expects the
coordinates to be in the form of a taboo
consisting of you know the latitude and
the longitude and you just in you just
call the get function in the library and
that so that's done executing and this
is how the output looks like it's like
it's it's a dictionary with the keys
being admin one and two for the
administrative regions CC is the country
code which is the two-letter country
code and this is the latitude and
longitude for the place which is
barbican so that's how your query for a
single coordinate now for multiple
coordinates library expects either a
couple of tuples or a list of tuples so
this is how you would define it and this
is these are the results
for these three coordinates and so by
default like I said the mode is too so
it's the multiprocessor mode you can
define a single a process by just
setting more equals 1 i'd recommend
using a mode one for like very small
inputs because you it would be a bit of
an overkill to use you know the mammal
multiprocessing so by small input i mean
anything less than 10,000 coordinates so
it would be sufficient to use mode 1 now
this is where I basically load a file
that contains ten thousand coordinates
so this is data from our users that run
speed test so you can see where I users
are coming from so this is how I would
load the file from csv into a tuple of
coordinates and so these are the top
five coordinates as you can see the
latitude and longitude are strings but
it doesn't matter the library takes care
of conway converting that into float and
you just call the search function and as
you can see it's done executing and the
output is written to the output files so
i'll just show you what that looks like
see ya oops so that's the input that we
had and this is the place the
administrative regions in the country so
it's it's quite fast in the way that it
processes the this input so for the
performance results I basically run
benchmarks on my macbook pro and you
know this is what the performance looks
like so as I said for like very small
inputs you wouldn't see like a huge
benefit in running in mode 2 but for
like 10 million court dates basically
more two runs in like about 27 seconds
on my macbook pro so it's really fast
and efficient in that sense one thing
I'd like to mention is that we also run
he also uses library and spark so within
spark since spark handles you know
scheduling tasks in two different
machines and cores I recommends using
mode one because I don't think you would
get like a huge performance boost by
running mode 2 if you're using this in
spark now applications so this is again
the data that i just showed this is just
showing the top 20 regions in the UK
where I users run speed tests and London
is number one so this is quite useful in
the area of doing some kind of
pre-filtering to basically focus on like
a subset of data that you have most
number of users and and it will inform a
lot of our decisions in terms of
marketing and stuff like that you can
also load that output CSV file into
Google Fusion Tables and filter by
region so you can see where you know the
users are so this is just showing you
the data points where users run speed
test with in London as you can see it's
got a pretty good coverage within you
know the Greater London region so these
are just two applications so I'd like to
end with just talking about you know the
contributions that I received from the
community so when I release this
initially this is only supported Python
2.7 so
and very soon like I started getting
feedback that people wanted bitin tree
so with the help of Branden and David I
was able to do that and quite recently
there's actually a supercilious rapper
written around this library this might
be the wrong audience for that but if
anybody uses C++ there's like a wrapper
around you know the Python libraries
this is how you would build it and use
it so with that I'd like to end my talk
thanks for attention this is my twitter
handle i will share the slides up on
twitter if anybody wants a copy thanks
questions yeah oh I have about 90 cells
instead of errors of GPS coordinates and
I was laughing transforms of it street
address house Alfred okay so obviously
Google to reverse it soggy ourselves
also so that's something that I have
tried to look at so I haven't found like
a database that I could use that
contains these addresses like geonames
has a lot of places so I could like
maybe drill down to like much finer
regions that can use but I'm not sure if
you can get you know to the granular
granularity of like a street and so on
so i'm not sure i haven't looked at that
problem
okay right okay right right so yeah yeah
that could be one thing that I could
look at so here I ages Julie excluding
fake ones but such as people inside
there could be someone I'm talk to Carol
the [ __ ] fundamentally it's tough it's a
little the ocean right so would it be it
is is it going to give results of I
don't have an idea if this information
or is it going to give me well it's it
what kind of results will I get it
somebody decides but right so it's going
to return a place that's closest to that
location so what I what you could do is
probably filter out based on the
distance that you know that location is
from the place so using the latitude and
longitude have some kind of threshold so
if it's really far away from the place
that the library returns you can
probably know that so that's probably
one way you can filter that out yeah so
you're using a KD tree but how many
points do you have any tree so that's
about 150 thousand places so that's
basically that whole geonames database
for a place that's any one thing you can
do is kind of cut things up into squares
and then each one has a KD tree
you can bucket so you know you only need
to have 1 K 2 3 4 London say ya think so
Game four words 50 right and check to
see if you're in a grid seller man using
KDE trailer right it right okay yeah
it's good idea yep thanks all right if
there's nothing else so this is like a
very quick duck thanks for attention